Scot how do you negotiate a contract
without an agent so let's say we've
gotten to point we're ready to sign
there's been many drafts the
screenwriters met with numerous people
and in my answers here they're not to
knock agents agents are great people and
they're they're vital in this business
but for new writers starting out I have
seen too many talented writers sign a
deal with an agent actors too and they
just they get stuck in a scenario where
they can't get out of and the belief is
that you need an agent to negotiate your
contracts for you or open doors for you
and it's really not true how you
negotiate your own contract it seems
scary because contracts are very scary
documents they're legal and there's all
these terms and definitions that are
overly worded in truth if you can read a
menu at a restaurant you can read a
contract and if you can ask the waiter
for mayo on the side instead of on the
burger you can negotiate a deal point
like it's not any different at a
contract is nothing more than common
ground it's a piece of paper that
explains how you and a production
company or producer are going to work
together what are the terms and and all
that so you basically just read it you
look for the elements that make sense to
you and that you agree with you
highlight or red flag anything that
seems awkward or intrusive or you don't
understand and you throw it back at them
and you say answer these questions and
we'll continue the conversation if
you're unsure of it you can always hire
a lawyer and yes you'll have to pay for
a lawyer but hiring a lawyer on a
one-time contract who's only working for
your better interest where as an agent
is working for dozens of writers better
interests more importantly they're
working for their own interest you're
going to get all the attention you need
you're gonna see all the details you
need to see in there and you will have a
valid source kind of vetting out all
those major questions on your behalf
when to sign the deal is there's no real
formula to it it's basically just making
sure that you're clear on all the the
requirements you're comfortable with the
money or whatever transaction you're
gonna have and
there you understand the flow the
workflow what action item you have to do
will trigger what action item on the
other side and you understand when the
term will conclude and how to exit it or
anything along those lines so let's say
we're at this hypothetical meeting and
I'm looking over this contract and I'm
like hmm you know what let me see
perpetuity what's that mean let me look
that up you know what actually can I
take this with me and and have an
attorney look at it because I don't I'm
not there's a couple things the scenario
let's say you'd say yes and they would
give the person what a week to find
someone and have them review it make an
appointment and then come back to you
and have any changes oh yeah and in
truth I've never been in a Serie it's an
area where I've seen a contract handed
to somebody and they're expected to
review it and sign it on the spot ah so
you never have to worry about that
usually let's take a hypothetical pitch
meeting you know you come in you're the
writer you show that a good amount of
confidence you treat it like the first
day as we talked about it's casual yeah
yeah it's casual it's fun you present
your ideas they seem to be in alignment
with everyone else you end the
conversation in a fun way which is like
you know well we seem to be in alignment
with a lot of our ideas as I just said
and I really look forward to being in
touch with everybody
you send a polite follow-up they express
some interest etc you bounce emails back
and forth and then when they're ready to
say you know we'd like to bring we'd
like to hire your services on this movie
or we have a movie idea that seems in
alignment with some of the projects
you've written we'd like to see what
kind of a treatment you could write for
us that'd be your first option and that
would be kind of a they would send an
agreement to you a word doc you get the
word document and you review it and
you'll notice that when you type
anything in it or if you adjust any
words it'll suddenly turn red on the
screen and it's called redlining it and
you get to put all your notes in there
you can add comments you can add
questions or if you have a lawyer you
can forward that Word document to them
they'll do the same thing for you and
they'll probably do a crazy job with it
called making it bleed so to speak and
they'll
you just email it back to the party and
you can bounce the contract back and
forth several times and you again it's
it's you're just highlighting the points
that you have questions about or your
lawyer does or your manager and you wait
for their response and they'll give on
some things and they won't on others and
you just kind of see what you're
comfortable with right so then this
theoretical email exchange probably with
numerous people cc'd on him would be
like you know we agreed to terms one
through five but seven we want to change
to this then see please see attached the
other thing else you're interesting um
so it's not where hey why don't you come
on in great here's a pen sign this oh
sorry you don't agree with this well
let's talk about it would have time to
review it you could review it on your
own terms where wherever you are show
other people it's not this high-pressure
think it's cut by a car it is not a
high-pressure situation and you should
never feel that you are being pressured
into signing something ever so it's it's
if you feel uncomfortable with the
scenario and they're not comfortable
with you when they're not comfortable
emailing you a contract or they're not
comfortable letting you show it to an
attorney they're probably not a company
worth doing business with any legitimate
company any legitimate entity is going
to totally understand that that flow and
they're going to be understanding that
you need to have it reviewed and it
takes time it's not like a
back-and-forth thing that happens in two
minutes they got a lot of stuff on their
plate you do too so you know take it I
would say three days is a good
turnaround that you receive it may be
send a thanks email just to let them
know you received it and then take two
or three days to really read through it
and make sure you understand all the
terms and then and highlight the
questions that you have and just send it
back so in terms of the studio being
flexible that's a good sign for the
screenwriter as well to see that it's
not high pressure in terms of
but but have you ever seen it where it
draws out yes and if finally it's like
look you need to make a decision here I
normally see it draw out the most when
an agent's involved agents tend to I
call them wedges lawyers can be wedges
agents can be wedges again these are
very smart savvy people who are very
valuable later stages in your career but
when you're starting out your first
couple of deals you really don't need to
deal with them intently I've seen a
really time scene really talented
writers have an option on the table have
a deal on the table I've seen the
company want to work with them and I've
seen the writer be very accommodating to
it and then I've seen agents interfering
calling conference calls demanding crazy
demands and increasing the money like
it's kind of stupid numbers where
they're not even really gaining all that
much for the amount of time they're
really putting in there it's more just
like the principle of just pushing
pushing pushing to get the most
exorbitant deal possible and what
happens is those companies will just
kind of say you know what we're done
we're not gonna deal with you anymore
and I talked about this in the book
actually as I overheard a speakerphone
conversation exactly like this where the
creative executive on a film said you
know what I really like the script I
really like the writer I'm not dealing
with you anymore and I'm cancelling this
deal and then of course the writers just
like I'm sorry the agent was like you
know like let's come up with a deal and
they just cancelled a call and that
writer got screwed because the agent
came in and kind of fouled up the deal
since an agreement is about common
ground if you have the writer and you
know the company they both have a reason
to be working together they can find
common ground and look it's always gonna
be you know you always gonna have to
fight a couple of points here in there
but it's always going to be common
ground
you